wines airfare anniversary area that's a
new Norfolk ferry lives don't matter
today right there I'll take a little
homie not LAPD style like you do oh and
you keep doing all your gangster stuff
I'm just trying to sell my house don't
worry about that everybody's just trying
to get along and have a good life all of
the races are different just because
they're different doesn't mean anybody's
better or worse than anybody
hey yeah where's the diversity I got to
do to my car
I didn't ask for it but the whole world
is watching what it's okay you don't
like me well I'm not out here to be your
friend I need to know [ __ ] pop off that
you got my back then hi to work in the
tab physical fellas like the face what's
my face with you and it needs a lot more
conjugal love tactic not winking me like
that I was like you 3-3 Adam nan show us
in room
we wait for the cavalry we are the
cavalry
what is
magic wand
like a nuclear weapon that grants wishes
that's whatever you want I'm gonna be
taller or shorter you want 10 million
dollars you're not feeling that why
[Music]
get out of this neighborhood
I'm gonna kill you then me and that's
when the stupid [ __ ] gonna start magic
water secure it
I already know in a nobody
built East out of the Academy no they do
not
you better keep coming
very short
I can't get out of my head that's the
start
[Music]
we might be enterprise we're not in a
prophecy
we're going to stolen Toyota Corolla
you
you